so always keep a close eye on that yes
well like she said in that piece chances
are a lot of people are running those
fans when it's 90 plus degrees 100
degrees yeah like on full you're not
doing the low one right
uh the strawberry saga continues once we
mentioned it yesterday all you viewers
oh yeah you stepped in the plate look at
this they sell those pictures yeah they
said oh wow this is nice it's a saga
yeah i just made that up
i want to make it dramatic sounds good i
wanted to make it dramatic it worked
strawberry saga strawberry saga
and i just posted this on social media
too
a lot of you have also been posting your
pictures we love this this one sent to
us by brian morrow way thank you so much
look at legion stadium right here the
background you can see the strawberry
moon just coming up over the horizon
current conditions sunny and slightly
hazy we have moderate air quality for
that small pm 2.5 that small particulate
matter for example like vehicle exhaust
basically your average temperatures your
winds staying light right now uv index
still up to 11. now it's way up there
and should remain that way especially
tomorrow 94 in centennial hills 99 in
north las vegas 101 for the east side
sunrise manor 102 whitney ranch green
valley henderson same for you these are
current temps 100 for southern highlands
97 mountains had so nice yesterday when
it was just low 90s just double digits
throughout the valley 99 in front 110
death valley hot out there 99 boulder
city laflin at 106 degrees so there we
go dry outside right now of course that
monster not returning just yet but we're
watching that load spinning off the
atmosphere here out in the pacific
that's going to slide on and increase
our winds paying attention to your dad's
day weekend because we know you're
making plans so saturday here's how it
looks 96 degrees it is going to be windy
on saturday and warm too we'll drop in
though below normal and then dad's day
down 10 degrees cooler than normal 90's
gonna feel great except we'll have winds
in the morning and then
a little breezy in the afternoon sunny
and cooler than the coolest spot
actually coolest day in our eight day
forecast here's more on those winds we
think they could top out at 40 or more i
would be surprised if they get up to 45
or more
in some neighborhoods by friday and
saturday still keeping those winds again
on sunday but not quite as strong
hour-by-hour forecast there you go 93
degrees at 9 00 pm 8 news 911. don't
forget to join us 87 degrees light winds
expected 81 by 7 a.m lots of sunshine
tomorrow 95. look at that by 10 a.m
we're already at 95 degrees that tells
you how hot tomorrow is going to be 107
our hottest day in this eight day
forecast and then the numbers start to
drop there's that wind on friday and
saturday cooler for dad's day and then
yeah we're right back to the heat again
to the century mark for sure by the time
we get to the first day of summer on
tuesday
you're watching eight news now your most
accurate forecast